so we started out by playing with
twisting our torso to move our arms
horizontally using our shoulder muscles
to move our arms
vertically and adding those together
torso
twist plus shoulder lifting to actually
create smooth circles with our whole
body rather than standing here rigid and
just using our shoulder muscles like
this and we basically played with that
with all four modes of timing and
Direction so here we have together Time
same
direction facing one wall but we could
also play with split time opposite
direction then if we turn and face
down the
corridor we have split Time same
direction same thing is going on in all
of these torso twisting is helping to
move your arms out to the Horizon your
shoulder muscles are helping your arms
move high and low and then finally also
in the corridor we have together time
opposite
direction key points to to focus on if
you're imagining a giant clock you want
to make sure you're symmetrically
hitting all
four of your cardinal
points as we're doing this we're being
aware of the center line of the body you
don't want one arm over here over this
shoulder and one arm down here under
this shoulder which aren't aligned on
that Center Line If you do this this
hand is going to get here much quicker
ER than that hand did so you want to
make sure your arms are always aligned
on the center line of your body so that
they can travel to the next point at the
same
time as I'm doing this I'm I'm moving
from this position by twisting my torso
pointing the center line of my body to
the next point I want to move towards
and that automatically starts to direct
my arms there as I separate my arms I'm
keeping them aligned on the center line
of my body and turning my body to get to
the next
point and in some way or another that's
going to work for all of the
modes for instance here when we're
moving in together time uh
opposite as I'm lifting
up most of most of the the movement
across the top part of the circle comes
from me turning my torso moving my
shoulder shoulders causing my arms to
move past each other and then then my
arm muscles drop down to the Horizon as
I drop from The Horizon down to the hips
the same thing I'm twisting my torso
which moves my hands past my hips then
I'm lifting up to the
Horizon other key points are that when
we're working on two different planes oh
wait who wants to be
assistant so when we're when we're
working in in the hallway in wheel plane
and we want to have each arm on a
different plane it's useful to work with
another person or like an inanimate
object to make sure you're not swinging
your planes in someplace where they
shouldn't be so I'm still twisting my
torso to create this movement but I'm
making sure that I adjust my arm
position so that I'm never actually
reaching in here and bumping into cheese
it's pretty easy to do that without
someone in front of you you but because
we don't have as much awareness of
what's behind us it's really useful when
someone or something is behind you so
that you can
check and make sure that you're not
turning too
far want to turn too far
[Music]
[Laughter]
then after playing with modes with the
arms and appropriate alignment uh we
talked about footwork footwork is pretty
easy to walk that way using half turns I
can do so by making front side turns
front side half turns with each
foot not only am I walking in a
particular direction but I'm turning my
body body pivoting on my heel or ball of
my foot
and I can also walk backwards by making
backside
turns with poy this is going to allow me
to move around and play with a different
movement while walking and moving around
a stage or while continuing to turn to
continue to turn essentially what you're
doing is combining a front side half
turn with a backside half
turn you may become dizzy if you do that
so it's useful to spot something that
you're moving towards so for instance
I'll pick a point on the wall and as I'm
uh pouting towards it I'm trying to look
at it as much as I can and when I have
to make my backside turn I'm going to
spot it as quickly as I can and keep
focused on it until I'm forced
turn turn my
head then if you get dizzy from a lot of
pure wets as long as you keep yourself
upright keep your chin upright uh and
spin around a few times in the opposite
direction uh that you've been petting
that will really help to get rid of most
of the dizziness very quickly